it's been seven long years since we've
had a white male president but with so
many white guys running in 2016
can you tell them apart alright who is
this white guy don't know but he looks
like he's crying I'm not familiar
actually yeah Lindsey Graham ya know can
you name this white guy that's the guy
whose name starts with an L so he the
Democrat dude I like to think he
represents Bob Saget um it does look
like Bob that is written whoo yeah yeah
yeah I read okay a whole lot of
attention Mike Huckabee Jeb Bush Rick
Perry Rand Paul
yep Rand Paul you're like obviously a
white person X who is this white guy no
idea
Martin O'Malley and that is his name
he's from Rhode Island
right yeah is this guy's name mm-hmm Jim
Hurst bucks strong shut Johnson or
lincoln chafee where's your ticket
lincoln Chafee do you have any hair
advice for him
yeah middle part not a good look for
this upcoming race how would you tell
them to style a
anything else out of these two who's
waiting he's definitely wider I would
say this guy here guy to the right yeah
Santorum he's like a walking or white
stereotype oh I know that very well yeah
big Donald Trump and annoying that
Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
not a very current picture is it Donald
Trump Donald one out of these guys which
one's the whitest white yes the waiter
there you go
Donald Trump I'll see you at the White
House